everything that Jordan says he didn't do
he's doing it's a bummer because it's
there and Peterson acts like it's not
this is why if you ever do a debate
friends just download all the books and
type control F and enter the word nature
it's pretty easy I actually I did that
for this I went to Capital after I saw
that lecture and I control F nature and
it took the the application of my
computer by five minutes to get all of
the references to Nature in the book
because there's so many of them
foreign
what's up guys so last month I did a
video looking at Jordan Peterson's take
on postmodern philosophy and lots of you
watched it and we really appreciated all
the comments and feedback but making the
video was hard not just because I had to
watch hours and hours of Jordan Peterson
lectures but because I had prepped so
much that by the time we started filming
I realized I had severely overdone it
what ended up in the final video is
about 50 of what I prepped maybe even
less in fact the video was originally
supposed to be about Peterson's takes on
post-modernism and Marxism but the later
stuff was cut all together but after
asking the chat community on wisecrack
live our weekly stream which you should
check out if I should finish the
Peterson project I'm here to cover some
of the material we left out particularly
we're gonna look at what happens when
Jordan Peterson tries his hand at
reading Karl Marx let's get into it okay
so to set a little bit of context the
video I'm going to use is is from a
debate that took place between Peterson
and philosopher slavoy Zizek now the
debate was meant to be about the
question of communism versus capitalism
and as part of his presentation Peterson
tried to debunk Marx and communism via a
reading that is solely based on the
co-authored political pamphlet The
Communist Manifesto if you're not
familiar with the text it's a short work
that was co-written with Friedrich
Engels now the aim of it was to be an
accessible and concise text that could
be read by workers around the world to
Aid in their understanding of the
exploitation of the working class under
capitalism and the necessity for a new
political system the manifesto outlines
the antagonisms between two classes the
bourgeoisie those who own the means of
production and have access to Capital
and the proletariat the working class
who need to exchange their labor to
acquire the means of subsistence okay
all that said let's get into the debate
and we're going to pick up with Peterson
and introducing his argument
I have to tell you and I'm not trying to
be flippant here that I have rarely read
a track now I read it when I was 18. it
was a long time ago right that's
40 years ago but I've rarely read a
track that made as many errors per
sentence conceptual errors per sentence
as the Communists Manifesto it was quite
a miraculous reread okay so Jordan
Peterson doesn't like the Communist
Manifesto he came in pretty spicy but my
initial issue with this is it seems
really weird to reference The Communist
Manifesto as the sole text that
represents Marxism and communism as a
whole for the purpose of this debate
it's a text he co-wrote with angles that
doesn't really get at the whole of his
economic and philosophical theories so
you know there's two ways we can
interpret this one and it's the good
faith reading is that this was a Earnest
attempt by Jordan Peterson to do his
homework and debate the intellectual
merits of Communism and Marxism on their
own terms because he thought that this
text was a good example of Marx's
economic and philosophic theories or
there's a more cynical reading which is
that Jordan Peterson is well aware as an
academic that Marx's mature economic
thought is located in other books like
the German ideology and capital and that
in making the choice to avoid those
texts he can instead focus on a pamphlet
that was written with angles and doesn't
really contain the fullness of Marx's
intellectual arguments and that's just
something that that kind of irks me
throughout watching this debate that I
would like to see Jordan Peterson really
respond to the fullness of Marx's ideas
and he doesn't and because of that you
could say that a specter is haunting
this debate
um the Specter of Jordan Peterson
not doing his homework what struck me
about The Communist Manifesto was it was
akin to something Jung said about
typical thinking and this was the
thinking of people who weren't trained
to think he said that the typical
thinker has a thought it appears to them
like an object might appear in a room
the thought appears and then they just
they just accept it as true they don't
go the Second Step which is to think
about the thinking and that's the real
essence of critical thinking okay so I
find this really interesting because
Peterson is implying that Marx and in
this case Engels did not take their
their whole arsenal to the critique
they're offering in this text and this
is a point where it seems like Peterson
and Carl have a lot more in common than
they realize you could argue that Marx
in most of his work is doing precisely
what Peterson's talking about right Marx
is analyzing the logic of industrial
capitalism which is assumed or was
assumed at the time to be a good and
logical system and he's looking for
internal contradictions and antagonisms
within that system when Peterson says
that you need to use everything in Your
Arsenal to see if an idea can survive it
seems like he's describing what Marx is
doing and Marx called this ruthless
criticism or in one text the ruthless
criticism of everything existing now
here's Marx and this is from a letter he
wrote in 1843. Mark says now philosophy
has become mundane and the most striking
proof of this is that philosophical
Consciousness itself has been drawn into
the torment of the struggle not only
externally but also internally but if
constructing the future and settling
everything for all times or not our
Affair it is all the more clear what we
have to accomplish at present I am
referring to ruthless criticism of all
that exists ruthless both in the sense
of not being afraid of the results it
arrives at and in the sense of being
just as little afraid of conflict with
the powers that be I don't know I just
find that interesting that Peterson is
describing something similar to what
Marx is doing and one could argue that
Marx is doing that in the text at hand
that's what you try to teach people in
university is to read a text and to
think about it critically not to destroy
the utility of the text but to separate
the wheat from the chaff
and so what I tried to do when I was
reading the Communist Manifesto was to
separate the wheat from the chaff and
I'm afraid I found some wheat yes but
mostly chaff and I'm going to explain
why hopefully in relatively short order
so I find this interesting because when
he says you know people and it seems to
be implied here that Marx doesn't go a
second step to think about thinking well
like Marx came up studying and
eventually critiquing the philosophical
work of Hegel a 19th century German
idealist now Hegel and the German
idealist tradition was focused on
precisely this right thinking about
thinking or maybe put differently
thinking about the possibility of the
conditions of thinking idealist
philosophy could be summed up as maybe
the most detailed thinking about
thinking in history of philosophy and
Marx was well aware of this tradition he
studied it it was included in his PhD
dissertation he wrote a book on Hegel
and Marx then turned this logical system
on its head by taking the method that
the idealists use to think about
thinking and using it to think about
history and materiality and politics it
said that Marx you know Kearns Hagel on
his head by making that motive thinking
about reality and not ideas and I don't
know I just think it's unfortunate that
Peterson doesn't seem to be aware of
that
here's proposition number one history is
to be viewed primarily as an economic
class struggle
all right so so let's think about that
for a minute
um the first of all is there the
proposition there is that history is
primarily to be viewed through an
economic lens and I think that's a
debatable proposition because there are
many other motivations that drive human
beings than economics and those have to
be taken into account okay so Peterson's
critical of the idea that he's reading
Communist Manifesto is making a claim
that four marks history is primarily
viewed as an economic and class struggle
and there's definitely truth to that you
know what Marx is doing is is reading
history dialectically now here's what
Mark says himself in the manifesto or
Marx and Engels say themselves the
history of all hitherto existing Society
is the history of class struggles but on
the word Society there's actually a
footnote in the text and in the footnote
they say that is all written history so
you know the full line is the history of
all written Society is the history of
class struggle so you know Marx is
specifying that he's talking about
written history largely European history
they also go on to say that this in the
manifesto in the earlier epochs of
History we find almost everywhere a
complicated arrangement of society into
various orders a manifold gradation of
social rank in ancient Rome we have
patricians Knights plebeians slaves in
the Middle Ages feudal Lords vassals
Guild Masters Journeymen apprentices
serfs and almost all of these classes
again subordinate gradations so in that
quote we see that Marx and Engels while
reading history as the history of class
struggle and antagonism are not always
just breaking it down to Binary
oppositions they seem to understand the
complexity of those relations you've got
to understand that this is a deeper
problem for people on the left not just
for people on the right it is the case
that hierarchical structures dispossess
those people who are at the bottom those
creatures who are at the bottom speaking
say of animals but those people who are
at the bottom and that that is a
fundamental existential problem
but the other thing that Marx didn't
seem to take into account is that there
there are far more reasons that human
beings struggle than their economic
class struggle even if you build the
hierarchical idea into that okay so here
Peterson is criticizing the manifesto
for presumably saying that all human
history is the history of struggle and
that that struggle and class struggle is
inherently tied to capitalism now
Peterson is noting that struggle and
human hierarchy of course pre-exists
capitalism and he's totally right and I
don't think that Marx would disagree
with him at all now Marx has a
dialectical reading of history in which
history is marked by struggle and
antagonism but it's not that capitalism
is the driving force of that it's that
capitalism when he is writing is the
most advanced stage of that historical
development
um let's see what Marx has to say
himself this is from the German ideology
and Mark says the first first premise of
all human history is of course the
existence of living human individuals
thus the first fact to be established is
the physical organization of these
individuals and their consequent
relation to the rest of nature man can
be distinguished from Animals by
Consciousness by religion or anything
else you like they themselves begin to
distinguish themselves from animals as
soon as they begin to produce their
means of subsistence a step which is
conditioned by their physical
organization by producing their means of
subsistence men are indirectly producing
their actual material life so here Marx
is grounding human struggle and the
particularity of humans producing their
own means of subsistence so before
capitalism or any other economic system
there is this fundamental relationship
between humans and nature and this
relationship and the struggle implicit
in it is the foundation of human
consciousness and society and Marx never
implies that this struggle doesn't
pre-exist capitalism there there are far
more reasons that human beings struggle
than their economic class struggle even
if you build the hierarchical idea into
that which is a more comprehensive way
of thinking about it human beings
struggle with themselves with the
malevolence that's inside themselves
with the evil that they're capable of
doing with the spiritual and
psychological warfare that goes on
within them and we're also actually
always at odds with nature and this
never seems to show up in Marx and it
doesn't show up in marxists Marxism in
general it's as if nature doesn't exist
the primary conflict as far as I'm
concerned or a primary conflict that
human beings engage in is this struggle
for life in a cruel and harsh natural
world okay this is officially becoming a
tough hang because right here Peterson
is accusing Marx of not thinking about
or acknowledging nature or not not even
acknowledging the existence of nature
he's is accusing Marx of not
acknowledging that a primary struggle
for Humanity is the struggle with nature
but Marx does that um so I'm going to
let Marx talk for a second here's marks
from the Paris manuscripts nature is
man's inorganic body that is to say
nature insofar as it is not the human
body man lives from nature and he must
maintain a continuing dialogue with it
if he is not to die to say that man's
physical and mental life is linked to
Nature simply means that nature is
linked to itself for man is a part of
nature so right here he's noting that
that contradiction between man and
nature is fundamental to human existence
and this is Mark's describing the
fundamental antagonisms that drive human
consciousness and history everything
Peterson says he doesn't do he's doing
let's let Marx talk some more this is
Marx from Capital volume one he says
labor is in the first place a process in
which both man and nature participate
and in which man of his own accord
starts regulates and controls the
material reactions between himself and
nature he opposes himself to Nature as
one of her own forces setting in motion
arms and legs heads and hands the
natural forces of his body in order to
appropriate Nature's Productions and a
form adapted to his own wants by thus
acting on the external world and
changing it he at the same time changes
his own nature so again this is Marx
describing the interaction between
humans and nature as fundamental to the
process of Labor fundamental to history
and fundamental to developing our own
Humanity so everything that Jordan says
he didn't do he's doing it's a bummer
because it's there and Peterson acts
like it's not binary class struggle idea
that was a bad idea that was a very very
bad idea it's also bad in this way and
that and this is a real sleight of hand
that Marx pulls off is you have a binary
class division
proletarian bourgeoisie and you have an
implicit idea that all of the good is on
the side of the proletariat and all of
the evil is on the side of the
bourgeoisie and that's classic group
identity thinking I want to talk more
about what he says about good and evil
or good and bad we'll get to that in a
second it's important to note that what
Marx is doing in the manifesto in other
places is analyzing economic struggles
specific to 19th century industrial
capitalism and this claim that there's
something akin to Identity politics just
doesn't make a lot of sense because Marx
is not talking about individual human
Identity or even group identity he's
talking about the way that humans relate
to themselves and labor under industrial
capitalism here is a quote from Marx men
make their own history but they do not
make it as they please they do not make
it under self-selected circumstances but
under circumstances existing already
given and transmitted from the past the
tradition of all dead Generations weighs
like a nightmare on the brains of the
living so just to be clear Marx is
saying that we live under certain
circumstances not of our own making and
we think and develop in response to
those historical conditions so again
he's not saying the world should be this
way he's saying the world is this way
it's an analytic claim let's keep going
because I want to talk a little bit more
about this weird moral argument he gets
into it's one of the reasons I don't
like identity politics is because once
you divide people into groups and pit
them against one another it's very easy
to assume that all the evil in the world
can be attributed to one group The
hypothetical oppressors and all the good
to the other and that
well then that's that's that's naive
that's naive Beyond Comprehension
because
um it's absolutely foolish to make the
presumption that you can identify
someone's moral worth with their
economic standing okay so Peterson is
making a claim that there's an implicit
and a priori argument in marks that good
is on the side of the workers and bad is
on the side of the owners and that's
just simply not true a prior arguments
are arguments that come before
experience or observation and that's the
opposite of what Marx is doing Marx is
doing an objective analysis of the
economic conditions that he sees Under
industrial capitalism he's not doing a
subjective analysis of the morality of
individuals he's trying to describe the
world as it is not evaluating its moral
standing and you simply don't see these
types of discussions taking place in
Marx's actual text definitely not in the
manifesto so by trying to read an
economic analysis as if it's a moral
philosophy Peterson just gets himself
all confused and it's also worth noting
that four marks it's not people or
groups of people who are bad or good it
is systems and structures and by
abolishing alienating systems it
disalienates everyone both workers and
owners so important to note that the
fact that that you assume a priority
that all the evil can be attributed to
the capitalists and all the good that
the bourgeoisie and all the good could
be attributed to the proletariat meant
that you could hypothesize that a
dictatorship of the proletariat could
come about and that was the the first
stage in the Communist Revolution and
remember this is a call for a revolution
and not just Revolution but bloody
violent revolution and the overthrow of
all overthrowing of all existent social
structures
okay friends um this simply isn't true
what are you saying here and I think
it's kind of dangerous when he makes
this claim um in his entire career Karl
Marx was fairly consistent about not
advocating for revolutionary violence
now to be clear Marx didn't make that
argument on moral grounds he thought
that violence could be strategically
problematic now to give the final word
here to Marx and Engels here's how they
describe revolution in The Communist
Manifesto in short the Communists
everywhere support every revolutionary
movement against the existing social and
political order of things and all these
movements they bring to the front as the
leading question in each the property
question no matter what its degree of
development at the time finally they
labor everywhere for the union and
agreement of the democratic parties of
all countries and I think that last line
is really important they labor
everywhere for the union and agreement
of the democratic parties of all
countries and that's something you see
in the manifesto their call for
Communists to work with Democratic
parties and parties in all countries
that support their aims it is not a tax
that calls for violent revolution I know
this because I opened up my PDF of it I
typed control F I typed in the word
violence I clicked return and nothing
came up so in case you thought I didn't
do my research I did okay and we're
gonna have to call it there you can
watch this full debate if you want to
it's on YouTube
um that's all I have time for today okay
so we did it again and our journey at
least for now is complete and much like
the first video that we did on Peterson
I don't know I find it disappointing
that someone with his very impressive
academic background in pedigree didn't
actually engage with the full scope of
Marx's work now whether or not one
agrees or disagrees with Marx's critique
of capitalism it doesn't do anyone any
favors to offer a critique of his work
that doesn't engage with the actual
ideas themselves and like his critique
of post-modern philosophers like Jacques
Daryl and Michelle Foucault it seems
like again Peterson isn't actually
critiquing Karl Marx the writer and
thinker but instead critiquing a straw
man version of what he perceives modern
neo-marxism to be we see this when he
brings up things like identity politics
when supposedly discussing the Communist
Manifesto the text which has nothing to
say about identity politics and it's
worth noting that I am not saying any of
this to just dunk on Peterson I gain no
pleasure okay maybe maybe a little bit
of pleasure in pointing out his misreads
of Marx but this is important because
again Peterson has a massive
intellectual influence and especially
because of his academic background and
credentials people take him seriously
but it's Reckless to present ideas like
this on such a public stage when he
isn't to use the parlance of our times
doing the work and even if you like
Peterson fine Marx's intellectual work
revolting I hope you can at least hate
him for the right reasons and not for
the things Peterson made up but please
let us know what you think in the
comments really appreciate you hanging
out for another one of these and again
check out the first video If you haven't
thank you so much to all of our patrons
for supporting our community check out
our patreon page if you haven't before
it truly is the best way that you can
directly support our Channel and you get
some fun perks you get videos early with
no ads some extra content and you get to
join our Discord Community where you can
talk about Jordan Peterson and a number
of other things so again thank you so
much for watching I'll catch you later
[Music]